good morning john i don't hear anybody
say this and i know that there's like
not a guinness representative there to
confirm it or anything but i'm
fairly certain that you have signed your
name more than
anyone else on earth you may have signed
your name more than anyone else who's
ever existed
and this isn't like wow what a profound
feat is more like
why would anyone do that which is the
thing that's worth asking like you're
upwards of 600 000 times now and so it's
a little bit like okay
what's going on signed copies of books
are a thing and they tend to be
more valuable there are a bunch of
really valuable ones out there harper
lee didn't sign a ton of copies of to
kill a mockingbird so one of those goes
for upwards of 20 000 bucks
jd salinger signed very few things so an
envelope with his name on it is for sale
for 1400
right now shakespeare lived before
signing books with a thing and also all
of his stuff is like super old now also
all of his signatures look totally
different
and all very bad but i'm sure if one of
them came up for auction some rich
person would pay millions of dollars for
it but john you have taken a thing that
became a thing and done something
exceptional with it and in comparison to
these people
whose signatures are worth tens or
hundreds of thousands of dollars
yours has an exceptional distinction you
have
the least valuable signature of any
author
in the world but also not i've got a
whole thing planned let me get there all
copies of the first edition of the fault
in our stars were signed
except there were a tiny tiny number
that were in effect
misprints these copies without
signatures were the result of mistakes
and that makes unsigned first editions
of the fault in our stars
extremely rare and rare things are more
valuable
and so your signature on a copy of the
first edition of the fault in our stars
makes it less valuable it has negative
value and yet you kept doing it you went
from 150 000 for tiffios to 200 000 for
turtles all the way down now 250
000 for the anthropocene review you have
flooded the market with your signature
it makes those books no more valuable
they
can't because they all are signed now
there are some rare ones that can be
worth more there are some that got bound
with two signature pages
in it that's a misprint as well that's
that's valuable and there are yetis and
spirals and pokemon balls and hangler
fish and whoever ends up with that
last page which is a handwritten review
of
what it's like to sign your name 250
thousand times like that'll be a nice
day
for that person probably that one will
be worth more
than the rest of them but mostly signing
this many times doesn't add
value except of course also it does
we've been talking so far about
like the collector's market and this
like really sort of
strange human instinct of collecting
things that feel valuable because they
are rare etc
that kind of value i think is completely
separate from the kind of value that you
are creating when you're doing this like
lovely ritualized signing thing
my thoughts are that this is a kind of
tangible symbol
of appreciation for the reader and i
think that like
all authors are really deeply
appreciative
of readers and we don't have great ways
to show it it's not about increasing the
monetary value of the book
it's about recognizing that readers are
more than just
numbers that they're people the words in
a book are the author's words but they
were put there by a machine we all know
this that doesn't make them any less the
author's words
but it is a kind of disconnect by
putting one thing in the book that was
not
made by a machine i think the book lives
in a different way and i don't know if
this is a thing that anybody knows
but the idea of signing an entire print
run of a book
wasn't a thing before you decided it
could be i remember those times it was
not an easy thing to get done but you
and the people at penguin figured out
how to make it happen and that's
reflective of a thing about you which is
that you like to try to imagine
different ways of doing things like
is something possible it should be let's
figure out how to do it and that's a
habit that i think is more well
reflected in this new book than any of
your previous books
and it's just like a cool thing about
you so i just wanted to say
congratulations
and that the anthropocene reviewed is
out may 18th you can pre-order it
wherever books are sold
and all pre-orders will be signed john
i'll see you on tuesday